it's going to be an interesting cycle
with RFK running for sure but there's a
chance you know everyone's really
worried about RFK but there's a chance
he doesn't get on the ballot right he's
running independent it's going to cost
him millions and millions and millions
of dollars to get on the ballot in all
50 states he may get on in a few States
but I don't think he's going to be on
the ballot in every state so it's going
to it's not it's not as big of a deal as
some people are making it out to be but
um we're focusing on 50 states I mean
that's that's the thing we want as many
votes in the popular vote as possible
all the way across the country so that
we can hit like at least a 5% or maybe
we do well enough in the media and we
get that 15% in some of the big polls
and we can get on the debate stage
because that's really what we want if we
can look Donald Trump and Joe Biden in
the eyes and tell them how bad their
policies are hurting the middle class in
America like that's what we want to do
you know cuz that's what really what
this is all about so that's that's the
focus for me at least my campaign all 50
states no Foreign Wars no Foreign Wars
uh you know try to dismantle the Federal
Reserve as much as possible of course
take down as many of these federal
agencies as we possibly can